2022 c'est le 50e anniversaire d'une
voiture mythique la renault 5 en janvier
1972 présentation de la petite nouvelle
au journal télé regardez-la se pavaner
sur les plages bretonnes la renault 5
d'une voiture compath longue de 3 mètres
50 proposés en deux portes et un hayon
arrière en voilà une voiture qui a
marqué les français à l'époque et encore
aujourd'hui simple pratique et modulable
la nouvelle pépite de renault est avant
tout destiné aux citadins c'est une
voiture qui consomme moins de 6 litres
aux 100 clés qui
est vous le disiez vous avez raison en
est une
se conduit comme un homicide
quatre manières et c'est surtout un
carton dès 1974 et jusqu'en 1983 elle
est la voiture la plus vendue en france
preuve de son succès la renault 5 aux
couleurs pimpantes et déclinée en
plusieurs modèles il en faut pour tout
le monde après l'a5 elle l'a 5 t elle la
sainteté s est la 5 gt elle voici la
renault 5 alpine le petit monstre de
l'ariège tenait la renault 5 alpine par
exemple plus puissante que sa grande
soeur elle est sortie en 1976 si vous
aimez les sportives elle est faite pour
vous vitesse de pointe 175
kilomètres/heure une voiture qui cherche
à séduire les vrais sportifs et puis
aussi les amateurs d'accélération est
aisé qui jusqu'à présent avait fixé leur
choix sur des modèles étrangers
après l'alpine une nouvelle version voit
le jour quatre ans plus tard en 1981
c'est la renault 5 turbo ce poids plume
de 900 kg a une carrure de leveurs de
fonte qui lui donne l'air de sortir
d'une bande dessinée c'est super cas à
bord deux places seulement mais le
plaisir de dompter paris bête se savoure
mieux en égoïste elle aussi en a sous le
capot elle est encore plus rapide une
pointe à 2 110 km/heure tout de même par
paix pour les courses de rallye à
l'intérieur on se croirait dans un décor
de film futuriste et ça laisse perplexe
certains journalistes à bord les
stylistes ont pris le pas sur les
techniciens pas moins de dix cadran mais
ils sont à peine lisibles et l'agente
anguleuses du volant est très
désagréable d'autres modèles suivront de
son côté en 1984 clap de fin pour la
renault 5 d'origine la production
s'arrête là super sinclar en place en
mars 2022 renault espère faire revivre
la célèbre voiture cinquante ans après
sa création au salon rétromobile à paris
la marque au losange exposé plusieurs
modèles parmi eux une renault 5 100 %
électrique attendue pour 2024
[Musique]